what are you watching on TV right now
Tuesday are you streaming anything are
you binge watching anything with your
lady nah not lately I want to go see The
Little Mermaid oh the movie yeah I
haven't seen it yes that is I I think
that's I think that's some real [__]
[__] yeah gotta go see a little mermaid
they spend 150 000 on her hair for the
movie they said no way yeah 150 000 yep
how the [__] did you do you spend 150
000 I don't you know what I'm not even
gonna ask that now you got to watch it a
woman a woman to figure out how
for sure did you watch the new Fast and
Furious movie no I want to watch that
too and I wanna watch John Wick John
Wick is [__] I haven't had no time to
do [__] John Wick's the one there's one
no that's the that's the best one have
you watched the the first three yeah
part four yeah part four somehow shits
on the other thing any anything with
with guns I'm watching anything with
guns yeah I love action movies bro yeah
no I think John Wick might be the best
action franchise ever yeah
you watch snowfall
no there's guns in there so not anything
it hurts are are it was a snowfall was a
little too like not modern for me it's
from the 80s bro yeah I can't now
what about Yellowstone oh [__] about the
80s you watch Yellowstone Yellowstone
Now Kevin Costner it's about Cowboys and
[__] no that shit's fire bruh fire fire
I'm missing out you gotta tap in movie
it's a TV show with Kevin cost see
that's the problem I don't I don't do
good with TV shows you watch movies I
watch movies when are you gonna start
acting [__] probably like next year next
year is time next year it's time yeah
I'm yeah I'm [__] every every [__]
show movie Everything how has the
transition been from the diamond teeth
to the normal teeth I'm still learning
how to talk less maintenance yes yeah
cause you got to get them [__] took off
and then you got to get your shits like
it's a lot because you actually for
people who don't know your previous
teeth were like permanents yeah so like
it's like no joke you're popping a grill
in and out nah this [__] was stuck every
day you got a floss you gotta like brush
and then you gotta brush every like two
to three times a day like [__] too much
man now you got the pearly whites pearly
whites they see my teeth they'd be like
you have such a beautiful smile yeah
baby 45 000. oh you're 45. well yours
look actually great you know a lot of
times uh
a lot of times when people get the teeth
things can look a little uh you know
I'll pay 40. I wasn't funny yeah yeah
[__] people should look big right I feel
like like hey hey you share your label
made the baby's got some [__] teeth
bruh yeah yeah he got wait he's got them
teeth you know what I mean him and a d
you know 80 from no jumper my brother
A.D baby she's not big no baby got them
bangs on them bro [__] up some corn on
the cob bruh yeah oh my God I never see
her [__] looks like but you know what
though I haven't seen baby yet when the
last time I seen baby
I'm gonna bring baby up here man I'm
sure he'll come up here soon he's got a
[__] hot record yeah no he love baby
he's a great guy I love it we're gonna
come up here together we got some teeth
though we're both gonna smile for the
camera your teeth look like they just
look like regular they look regular see
I won't lie that's what I wanted though
I honestly bro I feel like I'm I got the
best teeth out of anybody Tifa I ever
seen listen I'm not analyzing too many
teeths out there but I would say you
might be right
look at these shoes they look great like
this is nice team forty five thousand
dollars well spent hell yeah what the
[__] this is beforehand I had a little
Gap and see my sister was like that [__]
no hell no uh Lindsay I'm dropping next
or this Friday right it's Friday yeah
it's this week yeah comes out would this
be out okay this will be out we'll we'll
put this out Friday tomorrow okay
is today Thursday no we'll put it out
Friday so it's out right now go
streaming go stream the album Deluxe
coming soon yes Yes tour uh tour starts
really yeah tour starts well two months
two months almost two months it's
already sold out if you ain't got
tickets go [__] yourself yeah go [__]
yourself no way no don't go [__]
yourself listen hey see when I'm with
this guy I'm bad influence if y'all come
up here be ourselves the questions that
he's gonna ask you be prepared for him
this is for all the artists out there
that's trying to come up yeah be
prepared for the questions and be
prepared for this interview there it is
this guy's an [__] Tuesday my guy
boom